it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
we're out come on baby
hey bro put your blue blockers back on
hey what do you do me a favor these
don't sexy as [ __ ] yeah yeah sure dude
don't watch oakley's yeah yeah that's
fine oakley make some some cool
sunglasses but not those right because
i'm sorry i'm sorry are you
cam haynes because if you're not
you can't be wearing those because those
are for
active people so these are for like like
ultra marathoners guys who shoot bows
and arrows
dude
not for driving your white tesla with
white interior cruising around la well
here's what bob by the way yesterday
dude these are these are heavy [ __ ]
these look i look blind all due respect
to the blind i look like i'm i have
problems with my sight yeah and i walk
and i'm walking around
with i don't know they looked good in
the oakley mirror although i looked at
myself just now as washing my hands
in the [ __ ] bathroom with the glasses
on not because after i pee i don't wash
my hands after i never [ __ ] off i did
what i do is i i i purposely don't wash
my hands and i judge people that do but
i was washing my hands because i had a
little scope on my hand my fingers felt
sticky dope that doesn't matter scope of
soap scope that though because i use
that i use that in my invisalign and i
had it on my fingers my fingers were
little yeah oh gotcha a little scopy
scope and i looked at myself in the
mirror i was talking to chappelle and i
went i went like that oh my head looks
really oval super overall sometimes
you're looking man like god you ever you
ever going shopping and you thought you
look cool yes you're trying new clothes
on and you look in the mirror with the
stuff you came to the mall and you're
like god damn it it's such a bummer
sometimes i look at my girl why don't
you say anything so what do you mean you
want to wear them i look ridiculous i
look horrible she goes well that's how
you look my god i look like a giant
piece of cake and then i buy that thing
i'm never gonna wear it didn't [ __ ]
nick schwartzen call you an overgrown
lego no he said you know he said i look
like an italian lego
[ __ ] he's so [ __ ] funny he was
just at the omaha funny bone
i think or he was at i don't know i
thought
yeah
i'll be at the omaha funny bone by the
way but he's he just goes are you going
to be here let's hang out i'm like he's
just so bored and [ __ ]
nick is the only guy who got super
famous and stayed exactly the same
exactly the same never changed at all
he's [ __ ] awesome i mean i'd say
brogan too he's a guy who i mean but i
guess i knew him for being famous but
now he's at a different level i told you
when i hung out with the same guy it's
like hanging out with a politician yeah
you're just like
oh you have to move different now
because you're so massive you have to
but he's the same
he's just surrounded by different people
that look out for safety and make smart
moves like he just can't
roll around like we do but he's the
exact same he was just on schultzy's pot
because he's doing shows with joey diaz
yeah and tony hinchcliffe in jersey yeah
so he came early and then came to new
york to do schultzy's yeah i saw him uh
new show it's so fun you got to get high
it's so fun yeah
yeah man it's fun too because you know
rogan can i mean he's done finding kid
twice maybe once maybe once and called
in once no we had to go there
oh i'm sorry
no so he's done the infamous that was
the infamous
yeah
but that was that's what people forget
that was actual firing kid
episode it was released on fire the kid
but we did in joe rogan's studio and
just supposed to be just you and me you
were the one who said i remember we were
like
maybe we shouldn't air that because it
went live for but but but then we were
like
the only people that were listening
after we got done you guys are we don't
have to hear this man that we were like
no we're airing it i mean like in the
area you said it truth yeah but no but
it was huge yeah it was huge yeah it
used to be roman's biggest pot and then
elon musk said
hold my
blunt yeah and let me take it from here
yeah man that was the biggest thing
ever you you were like let's just air it
yeah it was a tough one so that we did
that that was fine a kid and then
remember when we were at fox remember we
were like in an office building yep and
he called in because i forget who i'd be
yeah i know and i go dude how the [ __ ]
have you not done the podcast i'm going
to do it if i win you got to do this
yeah i'll do it dude but then he called
in remember that well because and it was
after you had beaten matt matrione
and that's right and he was like yeah i
remember that that's right but it's it's
like he'll do
you know you didn't know joe then you're
like joe where's that we were cool
because i knew from denver right but we
were never like as close as we are now
but i was like what are you doing dude
you're so critical on that material
thing he goes yeah well guess what mitt
romney's a huge threat on his feet so
you know yeah i choked him out okay cool
but um
yeah so yeah he's never been in the
studio with us but it's because he
doesn't do a lot of i'm trying to think
he did like what ben shapiro's or some
some of those other guys pods every now
and then yeah very rare but very rarely
yeah and then him on uh other people's
pods fun because like with schulte right
he has the whole flagrant two crew with
akash and all the boys there and they're
just you know they're wild [ __ ] so
they're shooting from the hip and you
know rogan doesn't like you know
schultzy his new studio is ridiculous
put all this money into it it's like
state of the art and ron goes oh you've
complicated you've done too much like
this is this how it's supposed to be and
i bet they thought he was incumbent like
oh this is nice but you know rogan he's
like what are you doing it's too much
like wait what you know rogan's just
like oh you've over complicated it like
podcast champions right like in a weird
way so part of what makes podcasts and
anything that you see content that
people really like
the minute you start turning it into a
very
high-end production it's really
interesting people tend to go i don't
know like they can't they go i i now i'm
watching a show and it's not as it's not
as outlaws it's not as gritty so it's a
big deal
it depends on the talent because
schultzy has done that and he's still
he's still true to himself and so is
akash but then you know there's there's
different by the way i'm just going to
say this out loud if he [ __ ] said
game of thrones if he comes to la and he
doesn't do our podcast after he did that
i'm going to fight him i'm finally going
to fight him you guys always want to
know who's going to win you're going to
find out yeah he comes there then me and
him are fighting yeah i'm going to be so
there's that i'll take it personally
yeah oh we'll tag team them yeah but um
yeah so with it it is interesting
because originally podcast right
especially when rogan started maron or
corolla it was very meat and potatoes
but now you're talking about a different
there's argument for both you're talking
about a different game because you look
at like your mom's house with cigarettes
that thing is highly produced it's a
mini tv show
massive yeah you look at king of the
sting king the sting dude that's a
i would say it's the same production
level as like part of my take on espn
that thing's a monster yeah we have to
have outside editors you got graphics
you got submission videos like it's a
beast intro outros like it's a beast
several different
gameplay would have made you drink alone
i would add some whiskey i didn't know
oh you are you sipping are you sipping
on some someone's so in texas who's out
there tell kyle what's kyle doing what's
kyle doing dude i love that it's
ice cube and some but um you look at
people like caller daddy who doesn't
really even have video you'll get people
like uh armchair expert no video mark
man no video there's no hypothetical
video on those no
wow i think call of daddy might have
video now because when there are
barstool she did maybe now that she's on
spotify because they've added videos
she's on there but yeah aren't your
expert marc maron corolla like you know
those guys are audio first and
monsters yeah but then there's you know
there's different ones like pens right
yeah i mean you look at again you look
at sagura stuff or a lot of these other
people they're i mean you're talking
about a real production man yeah okay
like kane is sting dude we have to shoot
on tuesday and it's i'm telling you it
drops thursday nights at like 9 00 p.m
the editor and the people that go into
the production
it's till the nail to the [ __ ] second
to get it out i don't get the audio
until like freaking 8 30 8 o'clock yeah
because it's like right on the watch
there's so many moving parts in that
show and it's the most expensive show to
make like it's not cheap man [ __ ] yeah
because so much goes into it i'm i'm
editing my special right now you're
doing it yourself when i have an editor
okay it's a beast because i'm there yeah
i'm there it's the worst it's i [ __ ]
hate it i hate watching myself i hate
everything about it and i captured a lot
of what i wanted to do but um it's it's
it's the worst have you have you thought
of have you have you thought how long
you're going to do it
yeah so so that's the
problem be i could put out a strong 50
minutes
that might be a little long i'd like to
put out a 40 minute special so i might
do that the tighter 40s probably you
might do it but you got to kill a lot of
your babies but then i can take a lot of
those bits and let them live on their
own
i would i would prefer you release those
bits leading up to the special i'm going
to send you cutting together yeah please
tell me what you think you know what
sucks is when you send it like i sent
mine to stefano schulte
no they watched it like especially the
stef notes seven was
set the best notes was like i would do
this tighten this this i would do this
reference oh don't take that out because
it's this payoff and the stepmom was
great but isn't it it's the worst when
you send to somebody who you respect and
like oh dude i didn't like this bit like
yeah well that's that's my favorite bit
yeah like i could you do away with that
you're like ooh that hurts
so here's
so
so i think anytime you do anything i've
been going through this a little bit
because best of um has been received
[ __ ] really well on youtube the the
thing with dustin poirier and thiago
alves and it's been it was so fun and we
got a lot more coming but bring it up
chin we got a lot more coming it we got
great
great people on youtube really loved it
and i don't read
comments but i am reading them on this
because i'm going to start engaging with
people but dude it's pretty cool because
because i have to say that um that's not
that's not it um oh this isn't it that's
not it yeah that might be it
right
but the bottom line is it it's it's good
but then everybody's got points of view
okay it's too grainy there's like the
different things and you you can listen
to 50 000 notes and for me like after a
while you got to be like shut the [ __ ]
up i'm just going to do what i'm going
to do okay that's what i'm doing exactly
do you do it the way you want to be
careful with comments brian exactly and
i'm going to figure it out as you go
because people have comments and some of
them are right some of them are wrong
go back for me chin
to the very beginning uh no to the whole
page
to brian's page yeah
um let me no let me see the list that
had multiple
um
yeah see what i don't like b is
so you drop in one right you drop uh
basically 18 minutes yup and then uh
right after that you drop another one
and then right after literally hours
after you drop another one right okay
that might be my youtube guy
so i don't know
yeah
yeah
right i got to figure that out yeah
you guys are right in the beginning i
remember when you um first talked about
fighting the kid being successful yeah
it's just consistency like monday
wednesday monday wednesday one if you
don't have that you have to bank on it
that's why when we miss it
it's i don't know
i always go [ __ ] because i think about
my favorite pods exactly and monday i'm
like come on man there's not one like
[ __ ] or if it's not the original crew
that i usually listen i'm like come on
dude you know so there has to be
consistency yeah consistency
especially with your so with thick boy
like
there's a
there's a pattern right there's a
there's a foundation where it's like all
right monday's shop show tuesday this
wednesday this thursday is this so the
fans get conditions where okay we know
this strap but if you're just going boom
boom boom nothing boom boom yep boom
boom you know like a different it's hard
to keep up with it you know
it's good to know these are the things
and you gotta let them breathe too so
i'm gonna let them breathe yeah you know
let them breathe there you go otherwise
it's gonna be scattered like that like
fifteen two
three you know it's like scattered it's
weird i didn't know that they were doing
that i had to talk to my you see again i
gotta you gotta be involved in
everything and then but and then while
if you go back to then why is there like
josh wolfe on there meets twitter i
think because
that's from my youtube page is also
working with all those guys and he does
all this cross-pollination
to up views i don't know i have to talk
to her that is a little strange i don't
know why that's on my
yeah i have no idea what that sounds
like this one did well not crazy about
my youtube channel right now
joe right
not crazy about it let me see the header
on it jin the header like the the
headline
oh okay it's still your uh other special
see i would have up there right you're
like yes the name of your special we
create a graphic and then when it's
going to drop so when people go you get
familiar with it like let's drop in here
drop you know all right right now you
know yeah
all right ask daddy i hope it's the name
that we wanted
uh uh
yeah we'll talk all right we'll talk yep
we'll talk about it i have ideas on that
yeah
good
now daddy's doing a little bit of
traveling well daddy's gonna that is
always traveling that's daddy lives on a
plane daddy lives on his road where are
you from brian up here that's where i'm
from yeah i'll be i'll be doing it
all the miles i'm going to boston all
the miles that's right boston short
flight short flight short flight five
and a half hours that's right shooting
something for best up in boston that's
something cool lined up but then i go
right to a corporate gig i'll do that
and then i'm going to get myself on a
plane and go right to omaha nebraska
friday friday morning do two shows two
shows saturday come back on sunday
daddy's putting the miles in you got to
put your miles in like george clooney
from the movie up now if you fly if you
fly coach
across the country now it's going to
cost you coach it's going to cost you
eight hundred dollars well right no i
mean yeah leading to first class to
portland to other places like
the price has never been with inflation
and gas prices like the [ __ ]
nazos dude
like to someone who i mean just book my
airplane tickets
all the time like yeah he's always doing
every week he's busy
right now yeah because of fuel prices
and inflation yeah you're like what yeah
and by the way a first class ticket to
fly like just like i don't know four
hours is nineteen hundred dollars go
i'll sit in the back i'm not paying them
oh i i don't get it very rare i use my
mouth i see him for family vacations but
when i was doing my press store for the
special to go to new york and i was like
oh let's do first class they told me the
price i'm like
i'll use my miles due to date up all my
money it was like 4 700 his class from
here so expensive dude what [ __ ] you how
rude is that 4 700 but also they're
taking advantage of the consumer because
the pandemics basically overwrite so
then everyone's traveling now so like
during labor day weekend it was the
busiest time they've had in like three
years
so the airlines go cool story dude yeah
here's the prices yeah no thanks it's
[ __ ] that's rude
it's rude dude yeah it's very rude it's
[ __ ] something's going on in san
francisco i don't know because the purge
up there now but you see the one dude
did get recalled
right his name is horrible piece of [ __ ]
you know his name is a super progressive
uh district attorney well he was trying
to be a public defender yeah chester
boudin
yeah
now this is good for la because our guys
guess worse than that's that piece oh
he's next he was you know he was in san
francisco we got him from san francisco
how fun you know what look look people
[ __ ] there's a tidal wave going on
and it doesn't matter what your race is
or anything people don't like walking
their kids to school and having to worry
about some [ __ ] maniac
pissing on the street [ __ ] on the
street being a danger to you being a
danger to himself they don't want that
[ __ ] well it's down on that stuff well
it's like homeboy i don't know if you
saw this it was in venice beach
they this this he's a teenager like 18
19 takes a car
runs over on purpose uh lady and her
baby yeah runs over he goes she survived
yeah no that he they haven't gave him
his discipline yet but uh what's his
name uh uh uh uh uh gascon
goes oh wishing give him five months of
juvenile probation
excuse me it's a summer camp it's a
summer camp so what's happening then is
whether you're left or right they go
well that's not good and then you look
at the safety issues you look at the
homeless like what are you people robbed
left and right in beverly hills yeah and
even if they're pro left they're like no
we we'll take anybody else you know no
[ __ ] man
no okay in san francisco it's like
it's weird that we took garcon here
right yeah when he was in san francisco
where we had news in san francisco right
that'd be like
signing the worst quarterback in the nfl
him throwing 40 interceptions a game
going i want that
you know what let's bring him to death
well the idea is
criminal justice reform right it's like
all right well i don't know there is
punishment in the world not that there
for a reason
yeah i mean
you can't rehab like not everyone's
gonna be able to bounce back like
there's some just some bad apples in the
world but when you're just giving them a
slap on the earth and put them back out
like it's what do you think's gonna
happen we're turning to gotham city and
we don't have a batman bubba yeah
[ __ ] in the 70s dude it was like it was
all about rehabilitation so in the 70s
it was all about it was all about we had
to rehabilitate and the prisons became
schools i'm not against educating young
juveniles in school at all i would turn
them into [ __ ]
sports and they'd learn
they'd learn skills they'd learn they'd
be educated i'd do all that because you
got to do something when they get out
but yeah there's also something called
punishment you got to create a deterrent
to [ __ ] insanity you're the [ __ ] out
of here man you can't you can't have
people committing 47
misdemeanors or felonies how about new
york too how about new york and that
governor out there in the mirror eating
all the dicks yeah because same thing
there's two light on crime
that one dude had like 47 offenses and
they kept letting out i know then he
finally they got him because
pushed a lady into the train tracks like
how do you think this was gonna end how
do you think it was gonna end wait how
the [ __ ] did what do you think's
happening there clearly the guy there's
there's no there's nothing we can do
[ __ ] uh paulie malinaji was telling
me he got in a fight in the subway with
a [ __ ] crazy dude enjoy that yeah
yeah [ __ ] guy came at him and started
[ __ ] swinging at him paulie was like
oh wait a minute i was a world champion
he's like excuse me
yeah paulie's great love paul's great
he's a [ __ ] knowledgeable dude a
smart guy yeah yeah real italian
superhero
he's from brooklyn he's his dad still
his dad still lives in italy yeah he
goes back there and probably is the best
100 that's that's the best yeah great
and i thought meaning him would like
butt heads i didn't know him but he has
a lot of opinions but right when we got
together it was like an instant
connection
i love that dude me too there's nothing
not to love about paulie no play and
then he had the issue with connor and he
had the issue with uh artem and then the
mma community turned on him but he
forget dude multiple world champions
yeah a little respect please yeah it's
like add robin black on uh
fight night flashbacks and we did a
sit-down interview i haven't seen robin
black in years since we did uh
you know rogan with eddie bravo right no
he was he was on i think big brown
breakdown before then yeah but since i
came to showtime you know because he's
not a showtime guy i haven't worked with
him yeah and
last time i saw him he was like kind of
in this weird like gray area because he
was supposed to work for the ufc but
he's this
philosophical like artsy dude so he
doesn't really fit in with like anik and
dc and rogan so smart
super smart guy and just thinks outside
the box so he's like trying to
get him where he fits in but there
really wasn't a fit and the ufc never
really you know did anything with him so
then when i that's when i met him he's
like going through so he's lost and i
could feel his heavy i was like
yeah so then finally you know three
years later he's finally doing his thing
he's doing his thing we had a sit-down
interview so much fun man and then he's
just so knowledgeable in the way he
looks at fighting because on flashback
fighting he was he wasn't even a fighter
was he no no no but neither was anakin
he fought new liz
he did you did yeah i'll show you yeah i
wouldn't refer to him as a former
fighter no but he actually fought yeah
that's more cool he's studied he loves
things he's been a martial artist his
entire life but so the same as rogan
right martial's the entire life but
yeah oh he had some fights four and five
yeah okay
yeah um but he was a big musician
yeah yeah wow
yeah um but he's found his way and he's
just you know he's a really good dude
he's yeah he just looks at fighting
different than everybody else he was so
much fun so on flashback we let the
fighters pick their three fights in
their ufc career they want to cover and
we re-watch them you know robin not
being fired go pick your three
you know favorite fights that you want
to cover and he picked ronda rousey
holly holm when holly knocked her out he
picked uh mozzarella kale and ben askren
and then he picked connor winning the
155 lightweight title over eddie alvarez
none of those would be my favorite
fights
because there were so he asked
they have to be fast
tv [ __ ]
yeah so we can't sit through a five hour
decision yeah i i like i like uh like i
would say max holloway dustin poirier i
like those wars that went on where
you're like what what's going to happen
well that's how it doesn't wouldn't be a
war right because it doesn't beat the
[ __ ] out of him max holloway max
holloway gave it it still did some
damage on on dustin and i've watched
that fight twice yeah me too he
connected a lot
but he didn't have the power and then
doesn't hit him well that's right and
just rock that was a rough night for
matt very rough yeah if you're max
hallway fan you're not watching that one
but but there was like there's better
max hallway fights there were some i
mean there have been some just amazing
amazing things about if i gave you three
fights
uh if i if i had to choose to say
doesn't matter i'll tell you what was an
amazing fight was um and i was there for
it was uh
john john jones uh gustafson the first
one oh that's when i beat metronome yeah
[ __ ] war that'd be up there for me
too yeah that was a [ __ ] independent
if you're watching somebody else you
guys are gonna you know if you watch it
with a detailed eye that'd be fun to
watch and make a decision i i thought
i'll tell you my other one i'll tell you
my other one that was a [ __ ] whaley
against uh you wanna yeah and zhenji yep
they fight this saturday rematch that
was
one of the best fights ever [ __ ]
crazy yeah those are two good ones those
were my two good ones
um
uh i mean how how far back can i go you
know it doesn't matter yeah
uh i mean i thought that nick diaz john
daly fight
paul paul daley
knocks him down with a left hook and
then nick nick diaz knocks him out no
strike force though but yeah yeah but
that was that we cover it all you can do
strikeforce wc bellator out of
everything i mean it's a really bad
question though
we'll do guys first fights in random
promos yeah promotions but if i choose
it's tough right three fights stuff i
mean there were a lot of like i like the
frank mayor brock lesnar where he
submitted him with the knee bar that was
historic that was nuts
i like i like when frank yeah that was i
blew out his arm that was
crazy dude
i think we all watched it like when we
watched that together no i with rogan no
i didn't uh
oh i wat uh i like when um
andre alovski snapped uh i think no it's
frank mayer snapped himself his arm and
tim sylvia didn't know he's being
stunned here i know
he's so sick that was so [ __ ] sick
i'm i'm not francis ouster over him
crazy about him
brock
yeah yeah you like the dramatic moments
and you you like the wars i was going to
say robin the theme that he chose that i
thought was really interesting was
monumental moments in
mma history yes yes yeah like so so gsp
actually
as amazing as jsp was it might not make
my as far as fights are concerned what i
loved about gsp is he would find out
where you were weak he was so strategic
when he fought josh
he just kept jabbing his [ __ ] faces
yeah even with johnny hendricks johnny
anderson put a beating on him but he
just kept doubling and he wrestled
johnny hendricks but you wouldn't watch
those three you would not watch later in
gcp screen you'd watch him uh when he
flopped
yes
you'd watch gsb matt sarah in the tough
finale yep
what so what would you say were the
i like the upset fights i mean look hey
nate diaz and conor mcgregor yeah
the first one i'm not surprised
[ __ ] it's a fun fight it was
just to see the turn because yeah
because conor was boxing them up and
then they just went you know what
and the second one is great too with all
that those are
both great fights we were on our we were
both we watched those together first
fight you went like this you went
he's too big for him
and then the second one you were like
look at him pieces
nuts anybody who has any criticism those
are good connor [ __ ] mcgregor is out
of their minds yeah
i can't think who else uh well i mean
there was i mean and then you have the
ones where it was like the matrix when
you watch
forrest griff and
fight the guy in the box and silver
where you go
i haven't seen him it was a rough night
yeah
you fought um i thought no gear on the
floor oh boy we went out there all the
americans went out there yeah did not we
all got destroyed yeah okay it was a
tough night for me anderson silva
getting laid that night do you think
after he did that i don't know i think
that force is great you could watch what
kicked the ufc off bonner and uh forest
that's really what blew up that was a
crazy fight that was like because they
were both in the the ultimate fight
right it was the ultimate fire finale
for a season right it blew up the ufc
and you saw you saw like that's when it
was on spikes and everyone said like
everyone's calling each other going you
got to watch you and that went that did
that put that put that was where people
went this is that's what blues
no that's the most important fighting
you see is that true yeah it was the
first fight again the ufc hall of fame
like that's what gave them their
notoriety yeah
[ __ ]
do you guys remember duho choi versus
cub swanson that to me is great
and do you remember how it ended where
cub swanson just went like that he was
in his guard and he just went like that
and everybody went crazy that they're
like huge stars but it was such a great
fight it was an insane fight that was i
was thinking about that as one of my so
what so so your top top three
of just the most exciting fights the
fights that kind of were like holy [ __ ]
or do you go more with just
no i mean it's too tough to pick out i'd
have to sit down and go through it when
you go through there's so many good
fights so many a recent war that i just
came to mind was the uh the usman uh
colby fights have been amazing those are
great yeah i'd watch them every weekend
yeah i don't care about anybody else i'd
like to try out every weekend i agree
dude i agree
i really did
those are usman is just
made of different stuff just made a
different stuff
when pete sell and uh
uh was it stone hands
when they don't smoke
smith yeah yeah that was badass the
comeback yep yeah
um what are you what are you what's your
take on this weekend you got glover
fighting um yuri yeah um
you're you've been big on your i love
you yeah he's so why are you so
he's such a he's a freak athlete he's
just freak athlete he has experience i
don't care about looks what's his uh
what's his um
now you you're no i don't you like weird
right it's weird though all right you
like i'm glad he's not out of shape no
you i'm sorry sir
you are taken you are you
have a bias
you have a bias to good-looking tall
guys or generally good-looking you fell
in love with conor because he looked
good no no i fell in love with tonic
you liked his style and everything else
i like that he won right because we
can't with yuri he's won so many like
you can't co-sign yeah he has one [ __ ]
load and he's so creative with the way
he fights he's just so honest unorthodox
yeah what's his what's he came from a
kickboxing thing first or what he
he's weird because he was at uh that
super well show i did with dc he's thin
man he's not a big guy
he's tall but he's i love him you say
he's thin
he's pretty big no no no he's thin for a
205
okay yeah like he he he he looks as thin
as almost like a izzy like he's a thing
guys he's not really big really
and he was in you know he wasn't in camp
or anything i was like oh he's a thin
dude what would you say he weighs [ __ ] i
don't know the mate
220
ah i don't know if maybe 220 you saw
mark two yeah yeah 215 maybe he didn't
look like he might guess yeah he did 215
218 a lot of weight no yeah he does he
have big hands big heads sometimes yeah
bone structure you know when i saw him
and i i saw the hair and i go that's
your i didn't want to be like hello yuri
because i'm like what if it's not i'm
like oh i thought you were i don't know
if it was him either because he was so
like smaller than i thought i was like
he just looked to kind of blend in but
like he is a very handsome guy you know
and then the producer mayor was like hey
yary from ufc i'm like that is him wow
because glover's thick yeah like there's
some 205 which are big boys man yeah um
but he's like there was some training
size isn't his strength
really really nice guy yeah and and so
against clover you said it to get done
first two i mean i'm sorry yuri has to
get done first two because otherwise
clover are the old if clover starts
getting them down taking wearing them
out it's gonna get rough for you yeah
because you're always a vet yeah and
he's a good wrestler you said that right
phenomenal wrestler grappler his jiu
jitsu i don't know why it's underrated
but it's insane yeah and for a year that
could be probably he also won't be
quitting at any time soon he's no you're
not going to break all over yeah yeah
but again clover's older here he's you
know the young lion it's so incredible
that glover was able to do that though
nuts like it's actually getting
dominated by come on [ __ ] john jones
and he bounced back yeah nuts
so it's tough if you you know i'm such a
glover fan and that his story's so great
so you want to see him win but same time
new blood's not bad and here he has that
style that he can market you know so if
you're the ufc you're probably hoping
area wins because it's easier to market
there's new blood you know what's going
on with ghost system right now fighting
heavyweight he's fighting heavyweight
he's older he's out of the race yeah
because i mean if you're supposed to you
might want to get the clover you know
pretty one-sided fight
so it's almost like there's a hot spot
he must be feeling he must be feeling
like
the he could go back to 205 and get that
belt well he went to back 205. because
he was going to go to heavyweight fight
ben rothwell rothwell got cut because he
wanted more money so then now he's back
at 205 fighting
uh krylov which is a great fight yeah
really good fight are you uh
yeah that's
he's a monster what one do you have any
inside info on when jon jones is gonna
fight if he's doing that the end of the
year
yeah cause he's waiting for stipe and
apparently they came out to the end of
the year it's kind of a bummer but yeah
who else is fighting on that card
joanna whaley
25.
that's a crazy [ __ ] you want a whale
then chef chanko's fighting santos oops
yeah rest cards whatever but those three
are top three are amazing yeah yeah
shivchenko i don't know who talia santos
she's a monster should be undefeated her
only loss is a split decision which she
probably can you bring her up i just
want to look was i see if i've seen her
fight
she's a monster so she is she one of uh
shifting those tougher fights coming up
i think so yeah
shivchenko is just enough
chance of my draftkings parley but
i would put a hundred dollars on her
being i think she's a plus 800 plus 700
it's not a bad bet chef chance it's a
tough [ __ ] really customer
yeah valentino shephenko is such a
phenomenal fighter
yeah she's so good i know
her mom forced her and her sister to
train like her mom trains my mom's
badass dude really yeah interesting and
her sister is very pretty
yeah i think it's not a ship tank so now
it's only a plus 450 that's not bad yeah
i'm a fan of
i'm a [ __ ] fan of valentina ship tank
yeah
yep all right
here we go
and that fights during the is it during
the day or is it at night jen i think
it's a regular is it 7 p.m thing being a
double check
never do
no never do buddy
there she is
valentina
yeah 7pm pst for some reason i was in
the day because it was in singapore
how long is glover going to fight he's
but [ __ ] look you would have said
oldest champion ever i mean come on
you [ __ ] kidding
he's got to be 40. oh he's 43 i think 42
tomorrow it's so crazy he's younger than
me it feels so weird that he's well
fighting put some ages on for real like
fighting and he's been going hard in the
paint yes i mean the training your skin
gets the scar tissue but imagine what he
came up at he so first of all he was
this brazilian boogeyman brazil that
we've heard about hardcore's heard about
for years before he came to the ufc
because he couldn't get a visa but he
would come to america and train with uh
chuck liddell at the pit and that was
chuck liddell's main training partner in
his prime so he's been training at the
pit forever i didn't know that yeah and
then now he's based out of uh
connecticut which is strange why he just
does his own thing out of connecticut i
don't know
danbury connecticut yeah really
that's really weird
why who's there him the world champion
what do you mean i mean who else did he
train with he probably flies guys in huh
wow yeah he's not with like a big team
or nothing amazing humble
she's the oldest champion behind randy
couture that's so sick
that is
so unbelievable
yeah 42 i think year he's 29 you know
the young buck
yep
no electricity in the many of the homes
in his community and there was one gas
station coming up coming up poor
oh yes coming from the favelas in brazil
they did a like on the countdown for him
or the embedded they show he has like
this farm out there's like riding horses
and [ __ ] really puts the belt around a
tree yeah he's just he's a he's a farm
boy out of brazil
our boy tarik was like hey come out to
um idaho he bought a house out there he
goes come out to idaho yeah he moved out
there is he no longer he loves it out
there no he's in san francisco but he's
out there and he loves it out there and
he's like hanging out with his cowboys
and he's like dude come out and come
ride horses with us and we'll take two
days and wrangle cattle and i go i go
well i didn't know targ was that good a
rider but he is and i go i i i'm on the
thread with this cowboy who runs it i go
how good of a rider i can ride horses
but i go how good of a rider because
yeah you got to be really good obviously
because we're going to be you know
keeping the camera sorry are you kevin
costner for me yeah i ain't that gay i'm
also not flying out there from that
right now i'm not that guy two two days
in a saddle if you haven't ridden you
know what happens to your balls and your
legs the [ __ ] out the chafing and the
horde horses scare me and you fall and
you get trampled [ __ ] i'm not a
cowboy you know what i'm not a cowboy no
i'm a city city slicker my hands are
not for me i'm not gonna fly out there
to ride horses no
what galloping and keeping them ah yeah
get out of there like tar you know who
you called right okay spinning shirt the
answer is no but i appreciate the
offering
i go well i'll just videotape it for me
i'll get up on a horse i'll get up on a
horse and pretend
i don't know two days all right we'll
sit let me guess we'll sit around the
campfire and and chew on jerky and eat
some beans i'll [ __ ] i'm out i'm not
a cowboy no no
you know we're not cowboys it's
hilarious i like to pretend i am when
i'm in montana but i do it for the gram
and i jump off that monster
i'll go out there and hang out and i'll
just i'll i'll i'll get the horses ready
i'll pat them and i'll get them ready
and then i'll be i'll be back at the
campsite
making the food
like a good concubine yes dude i'll be
the 50s housewife i'll do your laundry
but i'm gonna do it on like the line i'm
gonna wash it in the river yes i'm
watching the river and we'll be singing
songs i'm gonna have a little dress on
my ass cheeks out the back yes then i'll
cook the chili for the boys yeah and you
and i will gossip gossip can you believe
that just a gossip a lot dude oh my god
have you seen that john dutton oh my god
his hands oh and did you see that rope
that he has
that rope and his did you see his new
hat i can't believe it girl and then
you'll have a little flask and i go oh
you stole some whiskey naughty don't be
like i did girl let me try something
yeah then we [ __ ] each other
hey catch us and then they then they
then they tie us up no because we're
both bottom so where it's impossible to
[ __ ] each other we just cry yeah we'll
figure it out and laugh
cry and laugh yeah and we serve
we serve nuts to butts yes and then we
do and we do a midnight dance for them
we prepared a little show for them
fellas on a long day sales there's no
entertainment
just the case thing ever fails
but there's no real music because we
just you know we have some guys like
no we have a guy
we're just doing little summer dresses
i'm all
shaking my dick piece out the front we
shave each other down no we don't shake
our dick pieces we tie it up no push our
dick right into the crack of our booty
no i don't i shake it nope you keep
slapping around no we're gonna i'm gonna
say that horse ain't the only one
packing heat i'm gonna take your [ __ ]
dick and balls i'm gonna wrap cinch it
up around it and i'm gonna pull it right
with a rope i'm gonna be able to see
your dick and ass right here bro in fact
you want to be you won't be able to lean
back in a chair cause that's where
you're i don't wanna i don't give a [ __ ]
and i'm full of chili that we could
you're gonna have a bad idea you're
gonna be you're gonna have a belly full
of chili and your cocking balls are
gonna be pulled so far back dude and
then i'm gonna have a little a little
pouch i'm gonna put it's gonna be in
[ __ ] jail and you're gonna do the
same thing to me and it's not gonna feel
good we're going to be in some serious
trouble if that's what it takes to see
those we are tana stars we're presenting
our man pusses
too much
no
well you know they do that in
afghanistan i'm disgusted
like they dressed the little boys up i'm
sure you know about this oh no they have
like i thought it was the sheep there
are a lot of there are a lot of
societies that when there are when when
look you separate
women are not around yeah guess what
happens i'm going to tell you this when
women aren't around and your body starts
looking real good yeah
this is what happens when women aren't
around and women aren't allowed you're
not allowed to be around women until you
get married
what happens is you guys are all hanging
out you know who gets [ __ ] the younger
guys who are you know who don't have a
lot of hair on their face that's what
happened but that's like i remember when
i was in high school and training you
know in training camp whatever four
weeks and the water girl who any any
other case if she's around other girls
you're like get the [ __ ] out of it right
but three weeks in you're like god damn
dude look at that
percent yeah just trying by dudes like
man yeah i i
see exactly heidi klum by week three
like jesus christ there's a guy i know
who was in a part of the middle east
wherever it was and he's an operator
he's like one of those you know special
forces guys and he said he was driving
they picked up this guy and one of the
guys was a young like he was probably
17. sure and uh he was on yeah and he
was and he was wiggling around he was
like kept moving around the back seat
and he was all [ __ ] up and he goes why
is that guy moving around so much tell
him stop moving around and the
interpreter said well he
he took a beating last night said what
do you mean a beating you know he got
[ __ ] last night
by some of the older
conscripts
and that was his turn and he was like
huh and it wasn't even considered gay it
was just like
there's no women around we're gonna
foster yeah it's not gay it's more of
like uh like a dominance thing i guess
do you imagine the next morning like
dude last night
like yeah yeah no doubt dude yeah and
you i i think
so much more common in some societies
throughout history when they didn't have
access to women i will guarantee the
spartans did a whole bunch of [ __ ] oh
if you read the history on the spartans
they would when they take over those
towns the first thing i do is rape the
women that's always the case and then a
lot of the leaders had little boys like
if they're going to tell the actual like
if the 300 movie was legit
i mean
those boys you know well if you read
leonidas was
which is you know the greek plato
socrates aristotle
what when when socrates is talking about
going back to
uh we'll go back
and have this discussion over wine and
there'll be lots of plenty of beautiful
boys yeah they need grapes and like [ __ ]
boys they're out of their mind
out of their mind yeah hey man you know
there's a surplus of women yeah you can
eat grapes and play with women yeah well
they might have been super
some of the greatest philosophies of all
time were might have been gay and they
had [ __ ] up and back then you know
yeah back then back then when you were
14 your life expectancy was probably 30.
you know so 14 was [ __ ] old you're
middle-aged you got married at that age
girls got married at 14. yeah and the
minute they had puberty in arranged
marriages the minute they had puberty
they were betrothed to dark days my man
days we've moved
you know the dark ages yeah hey b let's
take a little break take a little break
dude let's take a little break we gotta
pay the bills of the studio think boy
studio is not free sir it is not free
it's not free some stuff and i also need
money because i'm buying a lot of voodoo
donuts because i'm in portland portland
this thursday friday saturday that is
the helium portland june 9th through the
11th that's tomorrow night so here we go
9th to 11th thursday friday saturday if
you're in oregon then you go to portland
helium if you're in oregon yep or
anywhere if you're in if you're in omaha
though yes this friday saturday you go
to the funny boat you go to the funny
moment if you're anywhere in the midwest
take a drive and go see me it's a nice
drive and then if you're in norcal next
week i'll be in san francisco
comedy club friday saturday only two
shows friday two show saturday cobb's
company club is june 17th and 18th san
francisco i'm in the bay area so it's a
nice drive come on out fort wayne
indiana july 14th to the 16th uh san
diego california's july 21st through
23rd then the trash panda summer tour
ends in baltimore august 4th through the
6th whole new hour all shows a whole new
hour not from the green girl poppy
special so come get some come get
portland you're up tomorrow friday and
saturday uh i'm also in uh uh that the
milwaukee improv july 21 23 and you know
what check out my new youtube show
called best of why not on my youtube
channel check it out me moving around
with dustin poirier all kinds of stuff
we got python hunting that's on brian
collins youtube that's right ladies and
gentlemen but i'll tell you what if you
can check all this out you make sure you
got good sleep man because good sleep is
key and that's why our friends at helix
sleep they got you covered man because
we got you it's the only mattress i
sleep on it is the best mattress of your
life in this mattress it's not for
everybody it's built just for you all
you got to do is take the short little
helix sleep quiz takes two minutes then
they complete
you with a mattress that's perfect for
your thick ass body by the way you got
soft medium and firm i gotta be honest
guys i sleep beside sleep i was sleeping
on hay for a long time and i slept on
bamboo that's it blown out because
you're very [ __ ] you're very
disciplined yes and now you can have if
you like a firm mattress if you like
something super firm get it if you like
a soft mattress do that too but they got
it's all these mattresses are built for
spinal alignment
yep perfect matches just for you take it
from my friends at helix sleep they got
you covered just go to helix sleep.com
fighter take their two minute sleep quiz
they'll match you with a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life 10-year warranty you
get you get it for a hundred nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
you will so don't worry about it
financing options yep helix 8 is
offering the firing kid listeners and
viewers 200 off all matched orders and
two free pillows for the fire kit
listeners and viewers at helix sleep dot
com slash fighter
that's helix sleep.com fighter
look man if you're paying
overpaying for your drug
prescription which i know you are which
i know you are good rx can save you up
to 20. i love 80 percent not 20 80 80
percent i love
80 yep with good rx you can compare
prescription price at over 70 000
pharmacies to help you find your best
price all right again as b told you
eighty percent discounted rates good rx
is recommended by doctors pharmacists
millions of people across the country
that they've all saved money on their
prescriptions even if you have insurance
good rx could actually beat your
prescription copay yeah dude you can
save money all right good rx could
actually beat your prescription copay
price for simple smart savings on your
prescriptions check goodrx go to
goodrx.com fighter that's good rx.com
fighter goodrx.com
rx is not insurance but can be used
instead of insurance medicare and
medicaid in 2021 go to rx users saves 81
on retail prescription prices tiger got
a life lesson yesterday because uh
he left him and his mom and brother and
grandma grandpa left for chicago this
morning at 5 30.
so last night i rushed home after doing
king's thing and two shows with robin
black get home at five and they left in
calabasas there's this little area
common area where there's turtles so
they love the turtle they get ice cream
and you can see the turtles so they're
all excited about ice cream so we get
the ice cream they're like can we see
the turtles yes go check out the turtles
we're there and tiger was
he learned a tough lesson how nature
works there's a turtle literally this
size of a [ __ ] quarter maybe a half
dollar like little baby turtle yep he
goes oh papa look at the little baby
turtle he's so cute and bob's like a
little turtle yeah he's cute
[ __ ] big turtle
crash tigers oh
no dad do something like
it's i can't jump in the [ __ ] pond
and i go and then in my head i'm like
this is not good and tiger's crying he
goes dad save him like he went under the
rock dude i can't jump into the [ __ ]
tigers crying goes dad say my
you know what that is that's his dad and
he's he's not killing him he's taking
him back into his home to save him from
the other turtles
he was really oh yeah stop crying dude
that little turtle is saving him i was
like i should probably be honest with
him so my dad goes we're walking back to
the car and gets
you know he's such a sensitive kid he
goes dad i can't stop thinking about
that baby turtle you think he's okay and
i go he's not he goes no he goes but he
was i thought he said his dad's saying i
go that wasn't his dad listen this way
nature works dude it's the circle of
life right the turtle ate the [ __ ] oh
dude
i mean this massive turtle just conk
yeah
yeah i mean crush this shell there's no
way that my size so then hold up so then
as
you know that he's i'm like circular
life dude i go you know when we watch
lines yeah i go so sometimes
lines from other tribes the male lions
will kill the babies because they don't
want them to competition later in life
and then those lines that kill the
babies get older and they might get in a
fight and they get nicked and then lions
come along and kill them it shows a
constant circle of life in and out in
and out he was like this in the back
always be alive and then i got home and
i was like this probably wasn't smart to
tell him the truth
i should have told him the turtle went
home you gotta wait you gotta wait
because it's really hard for like a
little no he can't comprehend it he's
like so is that turtle alive and then
and then
he wasn't downloading all the
information then we got home he's his
grandma and mom's there he's like mama
we saw this turtle and he's crying and i
go no dude did it no again i told you
remember i told you the dad turtle or
mama turtle i don't know i can't tell
saved the baby turtle and took it home
he's like are you sure i'm like pretty
sure dude
i can't believe we went jump in there
and save them like
i can't jump into the [ __ ] thing dude
it's nature bubba when i when i was
living in calabasas we used to go get
ice cream and go watch the turtles and
my son when he was three maybe four is
this when the lady went off on him
remember that that's right now do you
remember why she went off on him i can't
believe it because he was grabbing him
right no because my there was a turtle
that was there and there was a little
dog there was a puppy
and the puppy was close to the turtle so
my son you know i i think i can't
remember but my son i think took a large
rock
and because i thought he had done this
and i had spoken to my my
ex later on and i guess my son in his
mind was protecting the puppy i was
trying to kill the turtle well he took a
rock and went
go douche and just attack the turtle hit
the turtle but he was like a puppy yeah
and he was trying to save the puppy i
thought he was just a psycho when that
happened i was like no ted bunny myself
and i was like yeah he shouldn't do that
but my acts later said he was trying to
protect the [ __ ] puppy maybe so in
his mouth for debate right no he said
that he was like a little kid he was
like the puppy was there somebody's like
don't get the puppy in the air and all
that stuff so the lady freaked out right
freaking the [ __ ] out and then my ex
and that lady got into it and i'm trying
to did they fight like i'm starting to
grab hair and [ __ ]
yes and my you know your wife took her
into the tournament she had all the
[ __ ] and your axe took that stupid
bitch's hair braids dunked her face in
the water and she died
and she killed her no my son then took
the rock and he bashed the lady yes
he murdered him yes
and and so we had to get my son out of
the country yeah and now he lives in
afghanistan yes so that's really what's
going on he's the young boy amongst
those gentlemen now
full circle i like what you did there
you brought it full circle you got to
bring it forward and he was the kid in
the van it's got to be bring it full
space
that was my long loss
that i don't pay attention to anymore
those turtles i mean nature's just
[ __ ] savages and then also nature how
about people serve like this family you
know their armenian or i don't know what
they somewhere in the middle east but
they have all this bread there dude
there's a giant sign and redlife says do
not feed the turtles or touch them good
luck and that tells you why you don't
you know when you touch turtles
salmonella yeah it's super bad for
carrie's women's great disease it's not
good dude salmonella this [ __ ] family
a big ass family yeah armenian something
i don't know and
persian i don't know probably purge
let's go with persian they're they look
like the people the 300 guys fought
right the guy remember the guy with the
nose piercing out the big guy right yeah
uh the then the guy with the quasimodo
[ __ ]
excited with them that's not no they
didn't look like i'm trying to describe
the those are personal i know what
person i know people from iran yeah but
remember the guy who was like this okay
so
and i'm like and i keep my son goes dad
can we feed him i go no and loud i go no
look at the sign it says do not feed do
not touch the turtles for a reason i
said dude you touch them i said they
also
bite there's also that your little soft
finger like boston's finger that [ __ ]
turtle's going to snap your finger off
don't touch them it was dad that kid and
these kids are like your son rocks
throwing them at them slapping the
turtles back in the water i'm like
this isn't there's nothing you behave
dude it's not yeah it's what you yeah
nature is metal you ever follow that
that instagram [ __ ] polar bears which
i didn't know in other bears too but
especially pulling now daddy's on
instagram when we started the show you
showed me a workout video yeah that was
funny
but harry the artist did that but
po polar bears bro
will eat
other babies even their own babies if
they're sure they will eat and yeah and
then there's the picture in nature's
middle the polar bears just
walking away with the face of his
of a little polar bear you don't need to
see that stuff you know what i'm saying
you don't want to in a zoo you don't put
a small polar bear
in a cage with other polar bears they
will kill it right away oh yeah that's
nature daddy i don't even see that dark
[ __ ] though you know well i'm absolutely
well she'll follow paul
male polar bear will there was this
especially where the female was running
away with her baby and kept running
because this male polar bear would take
him out was
chasing them and was going to eat them
and chase them from miles yeah i don't
want to see anything no i don't know got
away got away i assume it's happening
yeah well it's like i did a uh uh pod
with that thug nasty kid and he was
saying how
bryce mitchell he was saying how
he thought it was a baby turkey with i
forget what uh kind of a different bird
but it was a baby turkey he was like i
figured there's a turkey he could defend
himself the these other birds are kind
of softer so i put them in there with
these other birds so the birds killed
him oh they did
hours killed the baby turkey yeah he's
like but you know the turkey's bigger i
thought he'd be okay he's a baby well no
dude you toss them into foreign
territory yeah turkeys take care of the
turkeys birds are insane territories
birds are insane territory there's not
animal hate more on this planet than a
bird they're [ __ ] and they're also
stupid well no no bro i went somewhere
in calabasas off mulholland this steak
place and they they have peacocks
walking around like
the [ __ ] town i'm not stupid then
these grandmas are [ __ ] film on
instagram live [ __ ] filming these
stupid peacocks
ain't stupid certain ones aren't crows
the pros are smart i knew you were gonna
go there
pros are as smart as [ __ ] um dolphins
dolphins now now how about this they
should have discovered that some crows
well they're tools they'll put nuts down
there all the bait animals to go to it
and then but they they put
nuts down there and have the cars roll
over the nuts so they can get they can
crack the shells blah blah here's what
they didn't know about crows this is
fascinating
crows some crows i don't know where
they're from
they were they were seeing them
roll themselves down roofs so they'd get
to the top of the roof and just [ __ ]
roll roofs roof and a roof they said
they'd roll down the roof need you to
pronounce the f they'd roll down the
roof there you go and then land in the
gutter
and they were like what are they doing
they're literally you know you a kid
rolls down a hill
so the crows would be at the top of the
[ __ ] crest to the roof and go
row row row row rows for fun yeah do you
think that they're trying to make
themselves high
i'll try and get dizzy they're trying to
get into a different state much like a
dolphin would uh do does puffer fish or
they they do certain fish or or yeah
they eat certain fish to get to get high
but it's also a koala too and the the
ellipticus right
yeah they eat that because it gives them
a hot they're constantly eating it all
the time to be hot yeah koalas are the
snoop dogs of nature like they're
constantly hot
that's why they're all like chill really
always high always high
it's really interesting so human beings
are i don't trust qualities either human
beings aren't the only
[ __ ] uh i don't know if that makes
crows smart though yeah
i think it makes it a lot i think it
might make it aware of the difference
between
sobriety and an altered state
and what what's what's really
interesting about the the new research
on psychedelics is [ __ ] mind-blowing
like shrooms and stuff dude they are
finding that you can the 80 like if you
have if you smoke and you're you're
addicted to smoking
i think when it's done properly
psilocybin
you have an eighty percent cure rate
eighty percent of people who do a
protocol with psilocybin
one time to not smoke anymore can
literally stop smoking forever well i
know with like ptsd and like huge
fighters with huge yeah huge because
it'll fire up new neurons in the brain
that are dead well it also change your
concept of reality i'm not a mushroom
guy it'll rewire your brain it'll rewire
so if you have a major addiction um
or ptsd or whatever
a really strong trip done under the
right circumstances according to the
research can have profound effects with
what just one treatment and they don't
have a [ __ ] clue why that is lsd
psilocybin ayahuasca so you know dmt
right yeah do you know what ayahuasca
does you know what i didn't know this
what
so you you and i had that dmt trip and
it was like [ __ ] crazy i was gonna
hours by the way
and the reason is because i guess
ayahuasca the root or whatever it is you
consume it right it stops the brain from
breaking down the dmt um so it keeps
that dmt [ __ ]
going for eight hours i don't want that
right i don't want that i don't know
that's a long time because you can have
a crazy trip well i know a lot of people
with like trauma have had friends with a
lot of trauma try those ayahuasca trips
there's a place in in california you go
to it's like in joshua or some [ __ ] like
that and they do these monitored
ayahuasca trips and like neil brennan uh
chris rock but neil brennan swears by it
he's changed him he's a nicer person
he's changed the way he looks at his
outcome in life i know theo's done it a
bunch of times you know it's because it
affords you to kind of engage with your
childhood trauma and you you see these
realizations and i want to do it do you
i do
and i'm a little too old to have a
life-changing experience i feel like i'm
pretty buttoned down on reality and i
know exactly how to navigate this
[ __ ] life
and i and i and i also think that i also
think that anything you go through as
bad as it is is not a bad thing it's
actually you can decide to make it
your get your friend and your gift but
uh that would be one of like you have to
ask yourself what are you looking for
what do what are you what are you doing
and what are you looking for
right so
i don't know like it's like i
i don't think it'd be bad for you i
don't either
i don't either
but but
i i think that for the most part i can
honestly say about my life i'm living it
as honestly as i've ever lived it
honestly across the board maybe take
ayahuasca and maybe it gives you another
realization you know i wish i'd done it
earlier because you know what i would
have come to the conclusion of for real
what i would have come to the collusion
that i am i am a stand-up and a
podcaster i am not an actor i don't want
to be an actor i don't like you you
think ayahuasca would have shown that
though i don't know i think it might be
too much
it might enforce
it might have forced me to be it might
have forced me to be really really
honest with myself and i was always
pretty damn honest with myself but it
might have forced me to kind of
come to terms with
letting go of something i came to this
town to do now i was successful i'm not
knocking
yeah it's [ __ ] what went into can i
ask like the thought process behind that
i can guess and make some probably safe
assumptions but could you elaborate well
so do you ever got you ever go back in
your life and think to yourself i made a
lot of mistakes and i and this is what i
changed this is where i changed this
right do you think that if you did that
you would you make just different
mistakes right so is it it's kind of
impossible you're definitely gonna make
more mista you're gonna make mistakes
like just because you change
if if you could go back which to me is a
complete wisdom but so if you go back
and make different choices whatever path
whether it was that one or another one
you're still going to make mistakes you
think you had made a different choice
and been mistake free let me ask you a
narcissist well you and i had yeah you
and i had this conversation right over
text and i and i
one of the things i love about you and
one of the things that i think
i'm really impressed with about you
frankly after going through a lot of
stuff and everything else
is i think you become more generous and
i think you've become way more giving
and i think you've become and i and i
and i've always known i think i really
think that our my bond to you is was
always that at the end of the day we're
gay we're gay and i knew that your
values were so [ __ ] in line with mine
in terms of how much you care about
people in general yeah i'm johnny depp
everyone's still getting involved it's a
hundred percent true i just don't wear
scarves you're not as good-looking but
you're definitely not definitely
somebody yeah jewelry but you're
definitely somebody who has never
stopped
quietly trying to make other people in
your life better and you help a lot of
people okay
and the question is
that we talked about is that the best
route to go well
because you pay a price for it sometimes
big time and not only do you pay a price
for it but but the people that i that
are super selfish sometimes the people
that just only focus on themselves and
are radically about themselves but also
radically successful there are examples
that have those
demeanors are radically successful i
went is this
the proper way to go like do i need to
pull back from helping people no i still
say no because you get hurt or they take
advantage because you keep having your
examples that i had that i sent you i'm
like they're more successful than me so
but they're also very selfish very
narcissistic
is that more of a pathway to success i
would say that that's their nature and
that they're following their nature and
i would say that your nature is not that
my nature's not that and
i would say i i'm i think keep having
your heart broken
keep having your [ __ ] heart broken
over and over again you know why it's
worth it yeah you know why because you
do make a difference yeah and and and
keep doing things for people
because you can not for any not because
you get anything back because you don't
get a lot of time no you've gotten a lot
less back than you have but it's who you
are yeah and i uh the people that know
you yeah i i admire it i appreciate it
i've never not been that way and i think
it's a it's a much better way to live in
life so so okay i think it's a happier
life
i don't know but but monetarily i don't
know if it's the smartest me it feels it
feels honest to me it feels like i don't
know what i i
i don't do it because i'm like oh that
it's not calculated it's just like you
know my my lady is i love i'm more i
love my girl she's so smart to me and
she's like my partner but
i i was gonna call somebody's going
through a lot of [ __ ] and she said
you know you're wasting your time a
little bit on this in other words you're
not gonna be able to help this person
but i check in because i care about them
because it does make a difference but
you also know because you've been
through some [ __ ] just checking in is
help is a way of saying yo what's up man
because you never forget it you never
forget and those people that didn't
check in
i'm like your baby elephant yeah they
didn't check in with you or whatever
chris was dealing with or when rogan's
going through it you never forget that
excuse me you didn't check in after all
they've done for you well now i can't
[ __ ] with you now i'm out dude
i don't [ __ ] with any of those people
now i didn't go through anything that
you rogan or chris went through but
those people now i know you can't be my
foxhole when the going gets rough you're
out dude you worry about your own
things so i'm out and part of that is
also being able to forgive and just
forget it's okay it's okay it's all good
well i think but i think it also helps
make things a lot more
less
let's say less blurred because you're
like oh now i know that this is a
straight business relationship when [ __ ]
hits fan you won't be there at least i
know that yeah because if i was banking
on you i'm screwed yeah i also like the
the saying don't take anything
personally it's really hard not to it's
[ __ ] really hard but sometimes like
that can be really freeing because
everybody is doing their life
and like this this kid i know is 21 he
lost bo he lost his [ __ ] twin sisters
they were 17 years old in the car
accident they're identical twins and
they both
killed and he he he and his dad i was
hanging out with them and he said this
21 year old kid goes
he's in a frat and he goes uh i think
he's the president of this frat and he
goes but you know he was just kind of
talking we were laughing he goes was he
drinking a white man nope he just goes
he goes nobody gives a [ __ ] though no
and i go
that's the most important lesson and
it's not to take it personally
because nobody can give a [ __ ] at the
end of the day everybody's so busy with
their life that their job i hate to tell
you is they can't give a [ __ ] your
sister can you're really close family
maybe but everybody else let me think
about the celebrities that die it's in
the news cycle maybe
ray leota
just died yeah
maybe a topic for the newspapers the
media for two days gsp gsp was saying on
rogan he was like i retired you know i
got my head everything and he goes
nobody cares no nobody cares a new cycle
keeper what a bummer it's like you want
to hey let's stop every guys we have
because the to stop
supposed to stop now think about if
you're one of those parents whose kid
you know uh your son or daughter died in
the mass shooting
right now it's a topic conversation
in a week though like think about that
you gotta move on you're that parent you
have to d like your life's changed
forever the rest of the world just keeps
on keeping you got to keep on keeping up
elon musk could die tomorrow rogan could
die tomorrow it would be horrible we'd
be devastated the world keeps spinning
and the world keeps spinning turtles
keep killing the young colonels keep
killing the young yeah yeah
bash them in the face
so break yeah you're wearing the one
love shirt dude
i always wear it i like the one love
shirt gotten pee out of your dick
let's keep this going keep it going keep
the train going what the [ __ ] dude okay
go for it bro brennan's pen
you wanna freaking marks look at that
butt look at that button those legs dude
how do you
him though
mark where
it's levi's 531s 531s i wear those
what are those are those stretchy
yeah are they they're stretchy and
different i'm like oh these are the ones
because now they see like men lift
weights and have large quads and asses
yeah your your quads are stupid i don't
know how the [ __ ] you find jesus
that much but yes you don't work legs
that much well what i mean is like
i don't want them to even be this like
they just react they're just big
you know like other guys like you have a
barrel chest like yeah you don't need
the [ __ ] dude wait come to them you
have to go pee all right i was gonna say
uh the acting thing can they hear you
they can hear him all right not great
but they could hear him okay i'll ask
this stuff um
come back to
the acting thing
because i think about this too
is it about control because you're at
the whim of other people and you decide
okay what is it for me it was for me it
was very simply i i didn't like waking
up that early being on set 16 hours a
day stopping and starting where 15
minutes of your day is actually acting
and the rest is waiting correct the rest
is makeup and the rest is uh
adjustment and the rest is uh wardrobe
and the rest is a trailer i didn't like
any of the logistics of it yeah i love
the community and everything else i love
doing a play yeah but i don't like doing
a tv show
and when you do when you do a film
you're shooting one page a day [ __ ] off
yeah [ __ ] off with those details
i ain't that guy yeah i just can't do it
i don't care enough right and you do it
people refer to it like i had a 16 hour
day shooting it's like you were awake
for 16. it's a meticulous it is so
[ __ ] meticulous yeah it's so
detailed i've worked with the biggest
actors in the world i've been on the
biggest sets in the world yeah and i it
doesn't matter who you are and then
you're in the background of shots you
got to be in the background when when
somebody's shooting something in the
foreground you got to be in that scene
and you got to be doing the stuff you're
doing but you're not
you know it is what it is i love
explaining that to people have no choice
except how things are made and you go um
it's far more boring than you'd ever
imagine
being far more boring
you know that so is corporate law
you can make a lot of money but you're
going to be spending a lot of time
crossing things
and i have friends who are like you
think they're geared for that and they
get they're like i
have to step away from being a lawyer
because it's too boring and so a very
rare
percentage of people certain personality
types are going to be sort of like
inherently fulfilled by that but most
people find it tedious yeah even if you
have a legal mind i should be a lawyer
because i like to debate and think
logically and it's like well and then
you can be a lawyer you can be a lawyer
like a divorce lawyer and you see the
the worst in people
you see some [ __ ] man would you even say
um i see the worst in people i see that
i have a competition in me yes i want no
one else to succeed
ladies and gentlemen when i say i'm an
oil man you will agree oh i've got
across the state when i look at people i
see the worst
i see the worst
god he's so [ __ ] phenomenal yeah i
love that movie but yeah you're right um
brendan's taking a poo right now um it's
been a while yeah yeah but uh
you're 100 right
no i was i was curious because that's
part of it is like
now you've booked so many things it's
like well that's it's that's not been a
huge issue for you but like sometimes
like
i go like man it's like it's kind of
dependent on like do people give me a
chance or not and then yes the other
thing is
showing up to an actual [ __ ] job the
things you could do if you weren't bound
by a schedule of acting that yeah like
you have to not do your podcast or
whatever that's right when it's actually
fulfilling when it's actually fulfilling
be an entertainer come on in brenda
we're still rolling
just his quads and how he finds jeans
guys if you want the best supplement
if you want the best supplements how
many times you have to tell them
we got we got stuff for your brains we
got stuff for your sleep we got some of
your digestive health we've got daily
support protein bars nutrients like
strong tech greens you got key minerals
you got to vitamin d whatever you don't
want to go to the gym do you have
streaming on demand
up
30 you dumb [ __ ] yes we got decompressed
to defy we got [ __ ] mobilized
strength we got my warm-up your workout
ropes we got it all straight bases
kettlebells primal belts i feel like
punching you in the face
what are you gonna do about i'll take
one of their steel maces and [ __ ]
brain yeah yeah i'd love that man
someone's doing the steel club mace next
door that's right construction that's
right go to on it.com slash fighter for
10 off the best supplements on the
goddamn planet on it.com fighter 10 off
by the way i'm very excited we have a
new sponsor
toehold
tobacco i'm trying to buy into the
company i'm trying to buy into the
the flip-flops i always wear yes uh
these are these are basically herman oak
leather dude
yeah that that's that's the longer you
wear it the better it gets saddle
leather you can break them in top grain
leather there's full grain that's the
best leather you can find
and they look nice too yeah they're
beautiful well that's that would be the
elephant skin scraps you swear by this
company well i i they kind of cured my
feet um and they're beautiful but what i
love about them is they're
uncompromising uh the guy who makes them
by hand in vegas in his shop it just
doesn't compromise the website it's
called go to
shoptohold.com and t fat k
t fat k to get 15 off and tell them that
i sent you because i'm trying to buy
another company and that's how much i
love this company i want to i literally
want to own a piece of it yeah let them
know how much brian khan loves the
company
great shop
dot com i could beat you with this uh
this is the kind of thing where if i if
you were out of line i take it and i
smack you around a little bit well i
wish you guys had sandals when your son
tried to murder that turtle well she
took a sand with his face no i could
have hit that lady right there
or the turtle or the dog good for
hitting turtles
slapping sassy people and you can paint
brush their face and keep your feet good
yeah and you can throw them too and
that's shoptohold.com
shoptohold.com off that's it 15 off t-5k
don't wear them with jeans best
best quality
flip-flops on planet earth they will
last you forever yeah but you can't wear
jeans
nor could i afford them yeah
um let's see
here's the current event
okay
check it out
um
yeah what the [ __ ] about this did you
just go buy the boat or do it it's off
the jersey shore
it's an eighth yeah it's eight feet and
so
i know but does he bite did he hit the
boat what are we talking about here no
just a shark shark
that approached their boat off the new
jersey coast john plaza piazza said he
was fishing off the coast of seattle
city new jersey with his cousin son and
some friends
let's see how big
we got those and we have them right now
in [ __ ] malibu since i almost ran it
over my son was like pointing to it like
hey there goes a shark he's just
chilling ah
what do you guys think are you guys
scared or shut up monster that's not a
huge thing
remember that time you went on a shark
tour and
yeah there's no great way no because
that's what he's killing whales we're
around um
i mean i i'm
a yes and no i mean when i'm surfing it
doesn't cross through my mind if i'm in
the water if i jump in the ocean it just
crossed my mind you you bob around dude
you go like this you're doing this whoa
i love you he's doing all this [ __ ] i
definitely think about it but i mean
chance of it happened but you look like
a giant seal dude you're like this your
arms are here and you're like whoa brown
you don't get cold no man
you're a good swimmer too you're pretty
buoyant oh yeah i love to swim yeah
that's the ocean but it does cross your
mind especially when you get deeper like
god this is a guy
you me and brennan and chen everybody we
got to have a volleyball day it's so
much fun oh for sure you got to come
down i'll do that top gun stuff right
are you not going to do it
no volleyball
on a sunday
yeah yeah yeah no set it up
oh what do you got jim where's brent
i'll be there back in the day so there's
another one uh that i was interested in
the the cash in the uh oh yeah let's do
this
oh yeah attorneys going this is a step
back for women's rights it's like no
dude this is johnny depp telling his
truth yeah they decide that's the truth
it's not you know
guys versus girls this is truth versus
lies right yeah that's all this is
that's all but of course the left wants
to make it the the women movement to
step back no no amber hood heard made
you guys go a step back when she
did this wrote that article
to to capitalize on the metoo movement
we realized she's full of [ __ ] and then
johnny goes thank god johnny has all the
money in the world because he can fight
and this is truth versus a liar there's
no men women it's not it's it's got to
be hard for men versus women when she
walks the street the amount of hate holy
[ __ ] man yeah
um yeah and i thought it was interesting
because they i saw in good morning
america they said
um do you think it's a setback for women
and they said domestic abuse doesn't
have a gender and then specifically the
social media stuff they said did social
media play a role this allows them to
rebut what amber heard's lawyers said
which was social media influenced them
and they said i don't think it had
anything to do who said the truth who
said this this is johnny depp's lawyer
is coming on good morning america said
because heard's lawyers came out and
said and social media was influencing
but
look cause they said one of the jurors
went on tick tock and was like yeah
after yeah yeah look look uh johnny
depp's i mean amber hurst lawyers that
that woman sucks
and she's she was she didn't do a good
job and also her client was lying and
and america people can read body
language everybody was like everybody
was like this is this doesn't make sense
we're hearing the video and you're
saying something else get the [ __ ] out
of it the reason social media says one
thing is because it's obvious when that
many people it's like you know it's
99.99 middle school girls are like [ __ ]
amber heard they're calling her amber
turd yeah like amber turd was trending
for a hot second meepoo
accused them of being a domestic abuser
that might be a nickname you get a
mutual friend of depp and amber hertz
says i haven't seen johnny smile like
that in six years
yeah
[ __ ] yeah six years when they take your
everything away from you and everybody's
calling you a [ __ ] wife peter and and
and you're an a rapist basically where
you you you raped your wife with a with
a bottle and stuff and she was bleeding
that's a serious thing to say it clearly
has a drug issue which is we should
probably address but whatever but
separation
you don't walk away from that and what
does disney do hollywood went like this
johnny w biggest movie star in the world
see you we don't touch you
so i wonder what they do now i mean
disney's that he said he won't ever [ __ ]
this isn't it yeah
[ __ ] you guys that's what he said and i
think a lot of these people were uns
ceremoniously fired i was listening to
something this morning from the umbrella
guy who has been
my leading source of information for the
deaf herd trial throughout and has been
referenced by a few of these actually
like herds lawyers like this guy the
umbrella guy
he
was talking about how the people who
like fire johnny depp are out now or
like who's who made those decisions are
being held at the chopping block oh
really well because it's called due
process you you you had there was one
article written by one person yeah and
you go out uh we're out [ __ ] correct
you don't believe in what's making
justice system
it's un-american yeah you're like you
wait it's anti-justice yeah you thought
because you're ultimately true he's
making decisions about like you get rid
of this guy because you think he's going
to be bad for business
the opposite of that because it bungled
all these different things for no reason
when
you know hollywood's public sector
they have no backbone they're just they
don't have any ethics or more but knows
they have a backbone now because it's
affecting the bottom dollar because
america goes hold up hold up we like
john we believe johnny what do you what
do you mean he's fired from pirate
caribbean oh what the [ __ ] are you doing
yeah disney goes oh [ __ ] we read this
wrong oh we're not making money now okay
you know what we'll allow them back and
johnny's like no we're i'm good dude no
i'm not doing pirates caribbean eight or
where the hell they're on well i would
say pay me one billion dollars and i
want everyone to i want everybody who is
in the power what i would do is i say if
you want me to do pirates of caribbean i
want everyone who is who was part of
that decision out out i want them all
out yeah it's kind of going that way
fire seemingly
um that's what i would do what else you
got mark let's see there's a a woman
finds more than 36 thousand dollars
stashed in a free craigslist couch and
ends up returning it and gets a 2000
reward so i'm gonna ask you guys did
that happen to you guys
would you tell anybody no
what does your moral compass say i don't
know who it belongs to right i would
assume it was like
it might give it away
yeah because
some of it
your assumption would be hey are you
amber heard no
i don't know
why i pledged 36 000 cash did you pledge
it did you donate it yeah you're not
gonna do that but
i i would be more cautious like oh man
is this drug money is it an old
conversation
situation where you know what's
happening
that's what you get worried about yeah
like it's coming for their who's coming
for this thing yeah yeah
friendo i might i don't know
i'm out of anxiety for sure yeah because
the couch is in your house
yeah but you could also be like it's
like hey can we uh hey we left some in
the couch and we look like go ahead but
you didn't find anything in the couch
like no
yeah the couch just opened and the
stuffing's out you didn't look inside
yeah i don't know that came like that so
i i would well i'm keeping that money
yeah
it's weird that they just gave him two
grand they're like oh thank you here's
two grand of all things two grand they
get paid a grand for the couch yeah at
least five yeah i would say because
those aren't your savings like who's
just shoving money on a couch that isn't
involved in
uh you know criminal organization yeah
who just has 36 g's in their couch that
forgot about it
they're bawling so hard they forgot
because i would even say that they
probably got that couch for somebody
else because who puts 36 g's in a couch
and forgets about it so you're gonna lie
especially if you needed the money oh my
god yeah that was uh from my grandkids
college thank you so much and like
everyone gets a great story but like
that's yeah
i might call and feel my way out and be
like yeah so uh
i got the couch you know i found some
stuff in there some toys some change and
is there did you leave anything like no
not all but description say less
somebody might have died somebody got
put in jail yeah who knows i i'd feel it
out though but i can't uh i yeah i found
some stuff it was a toy i found a note
in here and made some other stuff i got
to keep looking did but did you put
anything in the couch like no we didn't
we but we got it from someone like oh
i'm good remember remember in old
country no country for old men when he
finds all that cash and all those dead
bodies but there's a tracker in the
money yeah oh yeah yeah i i've gone
through that a lot it was like tracking
money i just take that it's a scary
thing
with like you know if you've gone
through that a lot two million dollars
i'm saying oh you you've got my head in
my head what would i do
like you you would take you you got to
check that satchel for a tracker and get
that out of there man
like you found like two million dollars
get that get that air tag that's been
following you around
without sketching
all right so this is uh
we did some we did this on the shop show
and it's very sad remember that boxer
that was just like losing control he
started fighting the air
he died yeah
so he was 24 years old and we played
this on the shop show on monday
uh this guy he was actually kind of i
think he was like sort of winning
he
they're like gonna stop the fight
because the guy fell through the ropes
and he just starts boxing this ghost in
the corner yeah
you saw him be i'm sure it's on social
media yeah so internal bleeding in the
brain oh wow he passed away holy [ __ ]
that's so sad
something's going on after you guys
thought you would always get uh mris
right no absolutely not oh you didn't
know
you weren't taking the hospital after a
fight i mean it was a really rough fight
but no i thought you all had to be clear
right away uh it just depends like
before that after roy nelson yeah before
you before you were after right now
nelson after i got knocked out no i
didn't go to the doctor is that right
but they they said but it feels like a
war they'll make you you go there why
would you have cuts if you get knocked
out like that they don't they don't
check for brain bleeding or anything you
did they just like
your eyes and stuff yeah like you have a
doctor like how do you feel but other
than that maybe it's different protocols
now because you'd report something and
they would escalate to it yeah but they
don't know auto and by you i'd assume
because it's expensive yeah yeah wow
yeah that's terribly passed away i know
it's so sad we just talked about him too
no but also goes to show you that it's
not like the one traumatic thing where
it's like oh he got hit really hard and
then he died it was like
things were going well for him in the
fight
he was kind of winning he was kind of
winning from what the video clip that me
and brennan saw he was winning yeah but
he just when the referee stopped him and
he said come back together he just went
to the other corner and started yeah
yeah yeah yeah
he's like a mean combo on a ghost it was
weird
well that's not good yeah you can't be
[ __ ]
oh they're all [ __ ] up
all right so this is um an interesting
story
oh man the video is gone now that sucks
okay so anyways the video had a better
shot of all this stuff so this
couple
i don't know if they're like actually
boyfriend or girlfriend but a girl is
giving a guy a [ __ ] while he's
driving
he lost control and hit a fedex driver
head-on
and so this is like the
the scene app you can see the fedex
truck is right there i think in the
world according to garf the novel she
bites his dick off doing exactly this so
luckily there's he was in his dick
sucked and crashed yeah so he was
getting ahead and had a head-on
collision exactly he probably had his
eyes
closed his eyes i'm sure or he was
coming like ah are you looking i can't
stop
i'm sure you're gonna look down every
now and then yeah yeah control of it
right so yeah so but this is a picture
of the after who are the people on the
far right lounge your pounds are off so
you can tell this guy's a fedex driver
right that little shirt yeah is that the
guy or the girl with his pants down
exactly brian that's why i brought this
the guy and the girls on the far left
lane
no but the guy this looks like a girl
too oh i don't think so that's a guy
in some
upon first glance i'm like oh there's a
lot going on there's like two girls to
me
that sucks i'd have to get the [ __ ] out
of that he must be [ __ ] up no but so
there's no catastrophic reproductive
injury so they're fine all right but
imagine like a head-on collision when
the girl is like
going down on you
you know airbags you guys have
experienced airbags before yeah they're
horrible yeah so it's going to punch
your face yeah into your dick
you can force it you can get your dick
bit off exactly yeah if you had any
morning like watch out you're like you
know
but apparently they're all fine so it's
all good god damn yeah
well happy that feels really good hurry
feels really bad so i feel so good kind
of got a happy ending had a crash but we
have a happy ending
this lady yeah so this girl remember
when we talked about this
she used to sell her farts but now she's
selling boob sweat and she makes i guess
she's saying that she makes seven
thousand dollars a day from boob sweat
she's got nice boots
that's what she said she's hot as [ __ ]
but that's a lot easier than selling
farts non-stop she's like dude i'm i'm
gonna die if i keep
shiver faked apart
oh my god she's saying that it's it's
tough to get the boob sweat though
because yeah yeah you gotta work out
so tough she says my boyfriend is
breaking up with me but i have to
fulfill 50 tata sweat jar orders by this
weekend but then she says here that they
he didn't actually break up and i'm sure
she's telling the truth yeah
it must be so difficult got the hustle
she's sitting around probably with her
boyfriend like dude i can't keep farting
this i don't feel well he's like yeah we
never go out anymore you keep farting
she's like coming with someone else
she's like sell your tits sweat
make some titty butter
well
you can buy used uh undies yeah in japan
yeah if she could do that
though it's just some nice
she's yeah she's hot yes she's hot
uh the last one is this
it's very sad
turns out there uh there's a motion in
place to pass a bill to end gas stoves
is this new stuff in los angeles is this
new some it might he has to be involved
somehow but then all restaurants use gas
stoves right so what are they going to
do they're trying to so it's for it's
for the better it's electric stoves
they're going to they want all electric
that's going to [ __ ] your food up by
2045. it's not it's nowhere near but
it's already like it's happened in
different cities in uh california
already yeah so it's gonna ruin so many
different restaurants right yeah but
then they'll including cream barbecue
they'll figure out technology to make
the food taste just as good but i mean
you want to be hot yeah
you need the flames man you know because
you're a grill master oh yeah the flames
make a huge difference like flames yeah
well this this yeah i mean well yeah
korean barbecue is gonna suck dude that
one yeah it's good
barbie is gonna turn to the tesla
barbecue yeah i did it'll be okay but i
did in new brunswick i did the best of
with the steakhouse called uh stage left
and they're the they were grandfathered
in they cook their steaks over a wood
burning stove yeah they've been outlawed
for a long time so it's like you know
people decide this you used to you you
can't have a wood burning stove anymore
because that because wood produces
pollution yeah china in one year
or literally like a couple months
decided no more open-air fryers uh like
on the street because that's how
everybody cooked food and it actually
cut down pollution by 90 that's the
whole point of this whole thing but
still it's like
so luckily i get it but there's
different articles some articles say
that it's they're going to take it away
from restaurants that are already
established that are here but then some
say that it's just for new restaurants
grandfathered yeah i don't know yeah but
yes
you're going to be cooking on electric
stoves i know you have you guys cooked
on electric stoves it's not the same
dude yeah i mean air fryers are [ __ ]
lit yeah yeah but that's yeah that's
different it's different though
airfryers are good
that might be i love them the thing that
like
leads to this backlash like specifically
the korean barbecue being outlawed that
would be like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
whoa
i will protest we're not going to do
this shin's going to protest a lot of
koreans are but is that enough to make a
change no but but most restaurants use
gas grills that's for sure town might
succeed you know
what i'm just saying that block it's
like you know if all the plants there's
a lot of koreans in los angeles yeah
yeah there is huge population
yeah i would like some korean barbecue
right now i know
those korean short ribs that arowana are
pop and daddy and they've had them three
days in a row right now we're going
there have you had uh korean barbecue
burritos or tacos absolutely not yeah i
once ate six cookie bbq burritos in a
row they're amazing right yeah so i can
actually make you guys some bring it on
i gotta bring it next week i'll be down
all right you put white rice in them
i'll make it the way it's so good do you
want rice sure i can make it like as low
carb as possible though no i mean if
we're gonna do it you gotta do it all
right cool bring it in we need to find a
korean uh
barbecue food truck for food truck
diaries i know we're trying to do that
thing the vehicle but i dm them i think
it's it's not working they're not doing
it anymore
no there's a
screw some korean chris chen i'm liking
your arms thanks man are you working out
i told you brian about every episode
a little bit a little bit every day a
little bit every day your arm's getting
bigger
and that next and how's the neck
it's feeling pretty good because i got
the epidural shot oh freaking mark's boy
griffin that you guys know yeah he's
been like doing chiropractic work for
free for me
he's like stretching my neck
exercise i feel like it's helping yeah
yeah you look better
thanks man
that's cool yeah but i'm gonna reach out
to the actual the car i find korean bbq
in portland because i'm there tomorrow
thursday friday saturday no electric
grills portland i'll be in portland this
thursday friday saturday portland oregon
helium june 9th through the 11th through
the thick boys squad then next friday
saturday only cobb's comedy club san
francisco
francisco the trash panda tour continues
fort wayne indiana new club july 14th
through the 16th uncle was born there
san diego california the heart of san
diego downtown laugh factory san diego
july 21st through the 23rd then we end
the summer tour in baltimore august 4th
through the 6th get tickets at fatkz.com
or thickboy.com but portland you're up
bye-bye
omaha nebraska funny bone this friday
this saturday brian callan two shows
friday two shows saturday omaha nebraska
funny bone come get some and then i'm
taking a little while off but then july
21 20 20 to 23 i'll be at the milwaukee
improv i'll be at the milwaukee and
brave where my dad's from my paw was
born in milwaukee born and raised in
brown deer
and then
uh we got austin texas cap cities july
28th 29th 30th see you then is that it
that's it this is fun kid we're out